when I grew up you go to the beach there
was a sign that said no and all it's all
it was is fireworks or you know no
manslaughter
the beach sign gets something it's no
Frisbee now no digging holes no alcohol
no dogs like no no so you were living in
a place where the beach
if you think about the beach in the
ocean it's like it's a metaphor for
Freedom it's like I'm going to the ocean
or they sailed across the ocean to be
free you know and they landed in Venice
Beach or Pismo Beach or whatever it's
like it's literally it's like a metaphor
well in California there's a
never-ending list of things you cannot
do on the beach and every year they add
one the other sort of moving yes
no I have a couple of kids and I tell
everyone I will be attending their
graduation in a U-Haul truck and we'll
pull up in a moving truck
wave to them they're in there
a graduation and I'm going they just
can't admit they were wrong gay marriage
was illegal in Arkansas it's going to be
legal in California and then one day
Arkansas will make it legal and then
they'll look at us for right except for
what happened is we just kept going and
we've never stopped you know
foreign
hey Francis do you like locals I live in
London Mike so obviously not the only
pleasure I get from the locals is when
we show an intimate moment as we watch a
Japanese tourists get trapped in a tube
door
that is good but I wasn't talking about
their locals I was talking about our
community on locals you mean the one
where you get phenomenal behind the
scenes content when you the ideal space
we speak
when you get to wasp incredible guests
like Jordan Peterson Brett Weinstein
Bill Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Heather Hein and others your questions
not just that you can get supporter only
benefits like trigonometry mugs monthly
calls with our other top supporters and
even a regular meal with me and Francis
you also get phenomenal
behind-the-scenes footage of our trip to
America where we met a whole host of
incredible guests and gave ourselves
terminal indigestion we're also starting
to do monthly giveaways for locals only
the first one will be signed copies of
Andrew door's new book plus you get
access to an incredible community of
like-minded people who share means have
fun conversations and most importantly
you get to make new friends you can
support us with as little as seven
dollars or about five pounds a month or
give us more for the higher tier
benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
hello and welcome to trigonometry on the
road from the USA I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitten and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our brilliant
guest today is a comedian radio
podcaster author actor he's done a bunch
of stuff Adam Carolla welcome to
trigonometry thanks I'm just writing
something down you were just writing
something down listen great to have you
on the show thank you for first of all
for letting us tear up your set sure in
order to do this he doesn't look happy
about it
no that's fine I'm flattered that you
guys want to stop by and have a chat no
we appreciate that man well listen uh we
love you we're big fans of yours a lot
of our fans are big fans of yours but
there's also a lot of people in the UK
who are less familiar with your life and
story and stuff like that so who are you
what's been your journey through life
um I was I grew up out here not too far
away from this studio I was a carpenter
out of high school I didn't go to
college I wasn't really a good student
and I didn't you know take the SATs and
and you know forget about trigonometry I
didn't take Algebra I literally didn't
like everyone else took it in the ninth
grade I was thinking math took high
school math you know
um I grew up in a sort of blue collary
kind of semi-depressed you know divorce
you know sort of some welfare some food
stamps you know just a little sort of
impoverished to some degree and so I got
out of high school and I just went to
work you know and uh I just you know I
got a job just as a labor you know just
working on construction sites just kind
of using my back you know moving stuff
digging holes you know cleaning stuff
and it was sort of relegated to a pretty
you know Blue Collar kind of just you
know grunt work kind of labor on a
construction site I mean what I did
you know everyone who comes here from
Mexico or some other place who doesn't
speak the language and doesn't have the
proper identification if they they work
on a construction site as a laborer you
know so that's kind of what you do
that's the lowest kind of rung on the
socioeconomic ladder and that's I was no
different I was just born here but I
just went to work and I I you know I
work my way up and and I became a
carpenter at some point and bought some
tools and a Truck and and learned that
the skill of of carpentry and then at
some point I was just like man this is
hard and it doesn't doesn't pay well
that's kind of I don't like the guys
that work with and it's not very
interesting or stimulating or anything
and so I I made the conscious decision
to try to see if I could like make my
way into comedy some somehow because it
was only
two sort of tangible
assets that I had I almost said gift but
I was you know funny and I was good with
my hands those were like my two things
and I couldn't read very well I couldn't
write I wasn't going to work it was
going to be an attorney or anything but
I was like I think you could try doing
comedy so then I just started training
in in comedy in my kind of early 20s and
I I couldn't quit my day job I just work
all day and then at night I'd go take a
comedy class and improv class acting
classes something like that I'm just
work work all day have an apartment with
a couple of roommates and at night go
out and try to learn comedy man that's
awesome sorry friends let me just finish
this quick point so the the thing I
really love about what you do is you the
way you talk about it it comes from that
blue collar place of like the real world
right and that's what I think makes you
so interesting and so interesting to
listen to and and funny as well because
you're talking from a real space that a
lot of people connect with
um when we've traveled around the
country we've been all over the place
East Coast West Coast South you know
everywhere and I I have a feeling that
you have quite a unique insight into
this because we've loved the trip the
the we're so inspired by the United
States it's a great country there's so
many many amazing things going on and
yet so many people that we talk to are
afraid they're you know they're angry
they they're politically varied uh you
know it's a divided time in this country
why is that Adam
you know I the middle
is no longer an attractive place to be
you know it it it people used to kind of
strive to get to the middle like middle
class you know I got a home you know I
got 14 more years on the mortgage and I
own it you know free and clear and yeah
it's not much but it's mine you know
what I mean it's like a lot of like you
know we got two cars I gotta work on one
of them all the time but we got two cars
and you know I'm taking care of my kids
and I'm feeding my family you know it's
like a kind of a pride in sort of that
middle world and then at some point we
decided there was some nobility on in
the ultra Ranch and or the she's a
mother of 14 and doesn't have to piss in
but she's got her Pride you know what I
mean like it's this weird we got into
this weird kind of class thing and
everyone
had to kind of pick a side like oh you
want to be Elon Musk or you want to move
into a project in Chicago like and and
we kind of just you know the middle was
like you know but it maybe it was like
more like
like like you know the worst thing you
could say about somebody's our stand-up
routine painting or something is go like
it's okay you know what I mean like
you'd almost want people to go I hate it
I hate that guy's comedy I can't stand
that guy or he's a genius you know the
sort of middle is not sexy and it's just
kind of like we we almost like the
metaphor I always think of is like
if you'd like to go to the beach and
you'd like to not get pummeled by the
waves then stay on the beach or Swim
Beyond The Breakers where it's calm the
middle is just you getting sand up your
ass
but what's interesting about you talking
about the middle is you found Fame with
a character called Mr Burchell who in
many ways was in epitome of the middle
he was a guy in the middle who was
getting put upon by everybody and he was
just very frustrated yeah the I I Came
Upon that that guy Bert young
um I think you must pronounce it a
little bit but I'm not gonna hold you
down we're from Britain yeah forgive us
yeah I can say Benny Hill so
um but everyone could say Benny Hill uh
Burcham was a blue collar guy he was a
he was a shop teacher at a junior at a
junior high
and he was kind of based on a lot of my
shop teachers that were mean and hated
the kids and and so on and so forth but
the the appeal to that character so
I got to the radio
um well I guess we got time so here we
are I was a
I I was not having success in comedy or
radio or TV or or anything I'd been at
this point I would have been at it for
you know about about eight or nine years
and it just I'd been training but I just
never had any success
and I I came time to maybe get a shot to
do something on the radio but it was
only because I was working as a boxing
coach and I trained Jimmy Kimmel to box
and he was on the radio
and it it was a morning stunt Zoo stunt
thing where this guy was gonna box that
guy and they needed trainers and Jimmy
was doing sports he wasn't anybody you
know this is back in 94. so he didn't he
was sort of sidekick guy in a morning
radio and I trained him to box he
thought I was funny and so he said you
need to I said how could I get onto the
radio and he's like well you know your
boxing coach you know like how am I
going to pitch you as a comedy guy I'm
like well I do comedy but I just happen
to be a boxing coach
but uh well I won't tell them who you
are because they'll go it's the boxing
coach you know that guy thinks he's
funny but you got to come up you know
with a character and you come up the
character you can try it out on Monday
on the show you know it's probably
they're probably not going to like it
the guys who host the show but I'll I'll
get you in and so then I came up with
the wood shop teacher Mr Burcham and it
just became a like an overnight
sensation
problem with the way America isn't it in
a way that's
you were asked that you wanted to go on
the radio and you had something to give
but people just thought because you had
like a blue collar job that suddenly
like you didn't have anything to say you
couldn't make people laugh when actually
the reality is is because you have
experiences
you have far more of a connection with a
regular audience than people who went to
an ivy league university or college and
you know had come up just doing improv
and not having to worry about money
yeah I had a real kind of Base a
foundation and I and I knew who those
guys were the blue collar and the
teachers and and I I had this base and
and I had this base of knowledge because
I was a carpenter so my character the
thing that made the character really
intriguing is he was funny but he also
knew the subject so well that people
kept thinking I know this guy's a
comedian but I also know he's a
woodworker and a maybe maybe he's uh
maybe maybe teaches wood shop I I taught
um let's see I taught uh remedial wood
at Louis Pasteur Middle School in
Monrovia everything was made up you know
and then Mr Burcham was the guy and and
so it's like people would say things
and I I would take some phone calls
sometimes and like some woman I remember
she called up she goes oh that's my
husband's birthday and I went he's got a
table saw and I want to give him a big
Deluxe fence that's the guide for a good
fence and the guy at the store said it
was a uh a b uh he said something with a
B I said Bee's minor he's like yeah it's
a piece of Meijer yeah that's the best
fence yeah then they never want to go
how do you know all the the stuff and
I'd go I didn't say it on there but I
lived that life and then I just brought
it all into into comedy
and Adam one of the things that we have
in the UK is like it often feels like
most of the people who are on air who
are talking about stuff most of the
comedians most of the media
personalities they're not really that
connected to Ordinary People and it
explains a lot of the political
situations we've seen in in recent years
uh you you on the radio all the time you
talk to normal people like what do
people actually care about in this
country at the moment
people you know it kind of depends what
side you're talking about but like in in
general people live in this country to
be left alone
and and more and more there's a lot of
like what's the government going to do
about you know X Y and Z but most people
just kind of went their space and to get
along and and kind of kind of go go
about their life it's really the
you know I think the attraction of this
country is come here from wherever you
were once you get here just leave
everyone alone just go about your work
and by the way if you don't hurt anyone
or you pay your taxes then you'll get
left alone and then everyone will
everything will be copacetic and
recently
we started down this path where we
wanted the government to get more
involved with things which never really
has a good ending but somehow we decided
they needed to be doing more about like
with your kids you know the schools the
meals the who's taking care of kids it's
like I was like you take care of your
kids that's who's taking care of the
kids that's how it works and I would get
into trouble because I would say
you know they'd say
they're going to close the schools for
covid a lot of these kids are on meal
programs how they supposed to eat and
I'd say your parents are supposed to
make sure you're fed not the government
and then I don't want the government
feeding you starting at age nine I just
feel like that's a bad precedent like
that could go on well in your 40s you
know like and I've been on that end I've
seen what that what that inspires in
people like I I got a front row seat
like I remember when I was nine I said
to my mom why don't you get a job you
would get a job maybe we could have nice
stuff like a nice car or something and
she's like if I get a job I'm going to
lose my welfare like she was like you
gotta think boy horrible message but I
was like oh she's not working because
she doesn't because she's being
incentivized like she's capable of a lot
and then I sort of saw her atrophy
because it's like this person that could
have went out and did something was told
to stay home and wait for that check and
and it hurt her it hurt me it hurt my
sister you know we had to sort of front
row seat to this sort of lethargy yeah
and you know you are a penultimate
interview in the yesterday the only one
we've got left is Bill Burr tomorrow but
everyone we've spoken to in every place
we've been in we've been like I said in
New York in Washington in Virginia in
Nashville in Austin and now in L.A
California is supposed to be the most
liberal place in this country right from
what I understand and yet I feel more
restricted here than I have in any of
the other places we've been like you get
off the airport masks masks masks masks
you get in the taxi mass mass we went
into a cafe we've been filming like a
vlog of of our trip we've been filming
in every Cafe and Restaurant no one's
ever said a word except the first place
we come in L.A you can't film here how
is it that the most liberal place I mean
liberal means freedom the liberal place
in this country and that's the
impression that we get as visitors how
does that happen I I think you're spot
on or bang on whatever you guys say
you're on you're on
um well it is sort of devolved into that
although the people that are making the
rules look at it as evolving into it and
you know I always say this you know uh
Carol Shelby the guy built all the race
cars he he lived in Texas he's a Texas
guy and he came to Venice Beach
California in the 60s because he wanted
to build the cars
now obviously everyone is leaving
California now to go to Texas because
they want to do something and they want
the government to leave them alone you
know
it is a kind of a we California is very
blue it's very Democrat it's kind of
democrat super majority in any place
where the Democrats are involved and
have no
no enemies in the wild so to speak they
just start regulating and it's basically
you know I always say it this way
when I grew up
you go to the beach
there was a sign that said no and all
it's all it was is fireworks or you know
no manslaughter
the beach sign gets something it's no
Frisbee now no digging holes no alcohol
no dogs like no no so
you were living in a place where the
beach
if you think about the beach in the
ocean it's like it's a metaphor for
Freedom it's like I'm going to the ocean
or they sailed across the ocean to be
free you know and they landed in Venice
Beach or Pismo Beach or whatever it's
like it's literally it's like a metaphor
well in California there's a
never-ending list of things you cannot
do on the beach and every year they add
one so now it's 14. when my kids are in
their 20s it'll be 30 34 things you
can't do on the beach they never remove
them and so it's essentially California
is just sort of like if you took beavers
and you put them on top of the Empire
State Building
they'd go we gotta find some wood so you
go for what we gotta make a damn why
because that's what we do we're beavers
we're politicians we make rules and
California there's a checks and a
balance in other places and California
doesn't have that so you'll see a
sticker on every
thing in Home Depot that says
cancer-causing whatever is California
it's everything's California like if you
build
stuff
I build stuff you'll say like oh I want
to get the uh tempered glass railing on
the whatever they go are you in
California and I go yeah oh we go we
can't ship the tempered we have to do
the laminated stuff there and I go well
you can ship it everywhere else in the
country it's like yeah California's got
a rule they got a rule about everything
and they don't look at that as
oppressive they look at it as progress
but to many the people who live here it
feels not like progress it feels like
oppression
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russian men who clean are executed for
not being real men which is correct well
for those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped are the global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
a lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker ear
and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your werewolves might look like
a couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and we'll have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince Andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger 20 at manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code trigger
20 at manscape.com it's time to throw
out all your old hygiene habits and
upgrade your life
I take that on board with everything
that you say and it makes complete sense
but there's also the flip side of it
which is a homeless situation in this in
this state is out of control the last
time I was here was 2007 and what I've
seen just driving about in the short
time that I've been here I found
genuinely shocking well there's so
there's another thing which is sort of
the
beginning of the end of a civilization
which is California has in very intense
rules for people who pay taxes and play
by the rules I mean insane
amount of Regulation red tape
but conversely if you do not want to pay
taxes or you can then construct yourself
a shelter on the side of the freeway and
you will be left alone so basically it's
this
we have some of the most stringent
building codes and they're up your ass
every step of the way so if you want to
you own a home and you want to build a
gazebo in your backyard that's a
two-year permit situation there but
if you'd like to not pay taxes or
property taxes and just build a plywood
home in the park you will be left alone
and that's why we have over regulated
for those who are playing by the rules
and almost zero regulation for anyone
who wants to just slam drugs and live in
the street and why is that what's the
philosophy behind that from from the
powers that be
I there's a there's a kind of a
weird system which is like you have
money you can afford a home you know
that that homeless person is sort of
noble and needs our help and we're gonna
punch Up We're not gonna punch down and
leave them alone I I chronicled this in
a a book I wrote a few years ago which
is I started noticing
there's a street it's called Forest Lawn
Drive it goes by the cemetery and it's
three miles from here and so there's a
big Cemetery there and so on one side of
the street you have a lot of poor Latino
people who go down to the Flower Mart
not tonight
and they buy it's the most obnoxious so
they buy flowers and then they sell them
cheaply to people that are going to
visit Nana who've died four years ago
and and so on one side of the street you
have and it's a mess like the boxes and
the trash and everything on one side of
the street and they're just running a
bootleg flower shop from the street
they're just Street vendors you know and
street street vendors everywhere here as
you guys probably know okay on the other
side of the street there's a cop
and the cops on a motorcycle and he's
backed up the driveway to the Jewish
cemetery and he's got his radar gun out
he's given tickets
to taxpayers and soccer moms that are
going five miles an hour too fast Town
Forest line drive the other side of the
street is illegal activity going on and
first off they're not paying taxes
nothing's permitted they don't have a
business license they're undercutting
the flower store up the street who has
to pay insurance and and all the
expenses that occurred with running a
business in Los Angeles those people
operate with impunity and our government
is handing out tickets to the soccer mom
who's driving her kid to school I
noticed that about 10 years ago and I
was like something's broken here you
either have to bust both people or you
got to let the soccer mom go too
and so we start that's the path that's a
progressive path I don't know what I
don't know what's considered
compassionate about letting people just
sort of die in the streets or sell their
goods in the streets or all cash under
the town it's some compassion we also
have a racial thing too because those
are Hispanic people on that side of the
street and if you come down on them then
that's going to be like a bad optic
we're we're a mess we don't know I I
I went out on a boat with a guy who ran
the Staple Center which is now I don't
know the crypto Center or whatever it is
and I said to him I I walked out of a
Lakers game a couple years ago with my
son who's besieged with people with
makeshift hot dog carts and propane
tanks just selling street food but I
said it was all on your property it's
all on the Staples Center it wasn't it
was right by right this the door and
where did you walk out of the venues I
could bang into a guy that
he pulled out his phone and he showed me
a picture of one of those carts with a
giant cockroach cooking on it and he
said he said we hate it we hate it
what can you do I said well what can you
do you're you're inside charging 14
bucks for a hot dog these guys are
charging two bucks for a hot dog there's
no permit there's no license they're
dealing with food there's a health
ordinance or something they're on your
property they're just selling he said oh
yeah they they load them up in Vans and
they bring them out you know and they're
all cooking out front there
I said go to the city council you guys
are one of the biggest taxpayers in the
you you took downtown and resurrected it
by building the Staples Center you got
to be one of the biggest taxpayers
Employers in the city go down to the
commission the city council tell them to
clean this [ __ ] up we don't want this
stuff at it he goes I don't want to get
into trouble
what that's why there's exact words to
me so I don't I don't get it I don't I
don't need that kind of trouble what
does that mean it just means if he he as
the taxpayer who runs the Staples Center
if he goes to the city council and says
I want you to get these people off of my
whatever they'll go after him
that's I mean we did the same with covet
it's like that's that's just where we're
at that's why people are leaving have
you and this is what I was going to ask
you because when we were in Austin we we
did Joe Rogan's show and one of the
things he's trying to do is get a bunch
of people down there sort of like a
building you've seen have you ever
thought of moving yes
no
and that's why I'm a good interview
uh no I have a couple of kids 16 year
old twins and they're in high school and
they're coming into their junior year
and I tell everyone I will be attending
their graduation in a U-Haul truck I
will pull up in a moving truck and wave
to them they're in there a graduation
and I'm going Texas I don't know
Nashville Florida it doesn't it doesn't
really matter you know the thing about
California
is it's so screwed up
people used to come to California like
Carol Shelby with a dream you know
they've come here it was like Hey now
when I talk to and and I grew up in
California in California it's like you
would never leave California people come
to you you know what I mean like you
look at people in other states and go
well you bet you it's only a matter of
time for you come down here I'm not
going to you yeah and you talk to people
now and go you want to leave California
and they go yeah and then I go where are
you going and they go it doesn't matter
like that's how bad California's got
they're not even it's not like they
found a place
they think is better than California
they just want anything this is
different I'm kind of the same way it's
like ah Nashville or Austin or you know
Florida or where it's just like yeah
I'll I'll figure it out right but don't
you think there will ever be a moment
where you can sort of turn California
around because surely it can't keep
going down that path nobody likes to
live with the descriptions that you've
just described nobody likes to see that
even people who are just very much on
the right would be like well surely
these people need help you know they
need psychiatric help
we can't carry on like this and then
presumably I mean you tell me what you
think but you'd expect there to be a
political backlash against this like
people have been having their cars
robbed every day you know drugs blah
blah you know you know the full deal
you'd expect people to start voting not
only with their feet but also in the
voting booth well I you know it's kind
of a it's kind of a weird thing and so
you know I guess it depends on how
ensconced you are in in a way of doing
things like you know we had a tried to
do a recall on our Gavin Newsom the
governor you know he won by a landslide
my mom who's
I talked to my mom about it and um about
six months ago when this whole thing was
going on she's a lifelong kind of
Californian and and Progressive
I said so what do you think you know
vote for Gavin Newsom again or Larry
Elder the other guy
and she's like I don't know anything
about the other guy the Republican guy
she's like but I'm just going to play it
safe and vote for Kevin yourself it's
like all right baby more homeless people
like it's kind of a the way people think
over here is it's like look I don't
really know what Gavin newsom's up to
I'm not a big fan of that guy but the
other side those guys are racist and I
would much rather just have bad
governing than a racist running Larry
Elder well-known racist yeah yes then
the LA Times call them the black face of
white supremacy this is actually a black
guy grew up in Compton but he's
evidently he's a white supremacist so
that's what they do now the bigger
question is what the [ __ ] wrong with
my mom
I know the LA Times told you the
middle-aged black man was a racist but
don't you see a pattern forming here can
everyone be a racist who disagrees with
you right so the racist guy is for
school choice because he's racist like
why how does how does it work and the
answer is people are stupid they're
stuck it's a cognitive dissidents and
and and really what I think it is is
they just can't admit they were wrong
they just made a mistake like this guy I
know he's you know a Democrat I know
he's on your side I know you you like
him he's he's a disaster just you got to
go another Direction sorry you know and
you know people say
well
you know maybe when we bought him out
we're not quite we're not there we're
almost there but then when change
happens
when you bottom out and I go okay
so you have to bottom out like yeah
that's when the change happens so it's
like we're we got a teenage daughter and
we removed all of the nail polish
remover from her bedroom because she's
huffing it in a sock but she's not
flatlined yet like she's not OD'd
officially she just has a problem with
huffing
Varnish in the garage maybe we could get
her help now and their thing is like
wait till she ODS and flat lines then we
get hell and I'm like when we see where
this is going right like maybe we could
get a meeting now or some counseling now
like I see where the trend is going
we're bottoming out and in California
we're like yeah but we haven't hit
bottom yet
so we'll hit bottom then we'll do
something that's absolutely insane the
fact that they're thinking like this why
is it this why is this the most
Progressive out of all the states in
America
why
we just we decided that we lead the way
so and and we say it like politicians go
as California goes so goes the nation
you know we we think we're trendsetters
and so we think we're
setting fashion and Trends and you know
Hollywood and movies and we're very much
like we are the taste makers you know so
we sort of dictate so you know and and
we look at it almost like
historically like like if if if there
were two drinking fountains for black
Americans and white Americans and
California would certainly be the first
place to Outlaw that you know and we go
we because we set the trends you know
and
historically it's like yeah we do we
kind of set the trends and we're
Progressive and we'll show the way and
so if
gay marriage was illegal in Arkansas
it's going to be legal in California and
then one day Arkansas will make it legal
and then they'll look at us for right
except for what happened is we just kept
going and we've never stopped you know
so now we're like we need the guys
swimming with women and setting records
because everything seems like the next
you know progression it improves this
pool you can't argue with it and the
times get better everybody's happy
except the women right so that never
happens we just got caught up in this
we're sending we're setting the trends
you know we're going to have a third
transgender bathroom and we're gonna if
a male uh identifies as a female then he
goes right to the female prison you know
or she goes right to the female person
we look at ourselves like we are so
Progressive that you know we just kind
of go well what would they hate in
Arkansas
and be able to drink a beer on the beach
uh that's that's what they that's what
they want then we're doing the opposite
or you know that's just so
obviously there was a time when it was
like kind of a good thing uh we got so
far past that point and we don't we
don't pump the brakes so it's like
what's Florida want to do uh he wants to
keep the schools open during covet
all right close the schools you know
what I mean and then he wants to keep
the beaches open during covet close the
beaches you know that's that's how what
would Trump want to do he wants to build
a wall
no no more wall that's that's
essentially all they did was react to
whatever they just do the opposite of
whatever Trump wanted to do or whatever
a red State wants to do but they're not
really weighing in like hey if you close
all the schools maybe the kids are going
to commit suicide they're not going to
get freaked out but I don't know I'm not
interested in that they said close the
school open the school we say closest
hey Francis what do you think is the
best way to advertise a business that's
easy all you need to do is spend shed
loads of cash on an advert that's going
to be promoted on a dying medium-like TV
then simply sit back and watch all your
hard-earned money disappear down the
toilet what about advertising with
trigonometry why would I do that when I
can advertise on itv3 for the measly sum
of 20 grand and be watched by six people
because trigonometry now has over 350
000 subscribers across the different
platforms and gets 2 million views and
downloads a month that's right you can
place an advert with us and we'll
promote your brand on one of our
episodes your advert will be written by
two professional comedians yeah that's
right we're hiring two professional
comedians
when we make our ads funny and engaging
to the point where some people say the
ads are their favorite parts of the show
yeah we probably shouldn't admit that
mate all you need to do is contact us on
marketing
triggerpod.co.uk that's marketing a
triggerpod DOT Co dot UK advertise with
us and we'll get your business canceled
and Adam you mentioned both Trump and
Florida so DeSantis obviously you know
looking from the outside in America went
through just four years of absolute
chaos or six years of absolute chaos now
at this point what happens going forward
um well it kind of I guess it depends
now so people
will do this thing will there they'll go
Trump drove everyone insane he gave
everyone at Trump derangement syndrome
and so he drove over insane and then
they'll say if we can get some more
moderate type in there not Trump but
somebody's more moderate than we could
live with that but they will go nuts
over any anybody who gets elected who's
a republican because
they've kind of painted themselves in a
corner which is they've said anyone's or
Republicans are racist and homophobic
and
transphobic and everything phobic so
then there would be some concern if you
actually thought that someone who is
racist and homophobic and transphobic
and everything else was running your
your country there would be definitely
thoughts about that but I mean
they will
Larry Elder wasn't a racist until he ran
against Gavin Newsom who's a Democrat
and who's a white guy then the black guy
became a racist because I am not based
on anything it's a tool it's a tool it's
a tool that
is
bizarrely in ingested repeatedly by by
people if I was in charge of calling
everyone
a racist who who opposed me I would I
would feel like oh come on who's going
to buy it the 126th time you know it
just it can't be
some sort of magical equation where
everyone who disagrees with you is a
racist like it's pretty Preposterous
notion but they're going we're going
we're going back to that again and they
just
they just do and I don't I so you don't
think DeSantis you can say well look I'm
from a Latino background you know I mean
obviously didn't work for Larry Elder
you don't you don't think that a more
moderate person like him because let's
be honest Trump was incendiary yes on
purpose yes right yes a more moderate
person who who has many of the same
policies who's confident who looks good
sounds good blah blah blah blah you
don't think that that will help uh yeah
I mean it'll it'll get it a little
anything but Trump
for sure but they will go nuts on
DeSantis I mean they're already starting
with him because they feel like maybe
he's viable or something like that so
there's going to be lots of hit pieces
on him and it'll it's the same Playbook
to find misogyny races some covid stuff
where he didn't care you know whatever
whatever they're gonna do but they'll
they'll do it I don't I don't really
know what the end game is and I'm not
sure why so many people
go along with it I interviewed a
oh God I'll think of his name Glenn
Washington I think his name's a black
man who is the
I didn't work for NPR or something like
that and and he he unfortunately came in
here the day after Trump was elected and
he's like I got to talk to my kids about
where we're living now like what what's
I got to tell them I gotta look over
their shoulder you know the Run
Serpentine to the mailbox and everything
and it's like what do you think Trump's
doing out hunting black people what do
you think his policy is he just
tell your son go to school you know go
go enjoy your life he he lives in San
Francisco
he's like oh man I gotta talk to my kid
and I'm like I I don't know I don't
don't talk to your kid by the way you're
going to screw him up but also like
do you think like what do you think is
going on and I I don't know the answer I
did do they believe it like what do they
I mean I had
he had so many people like freaking out
like I got to talk to my kid I gotta
leave the country it's like whatever and
he's going to you know X Y and Z and and
I'm like all right but after X amount of
years and nothing happens or is it okay
and they're like he wanted it went it
went from like he's going to do this to
he wanted to do it now yeah it's now yes
we're in some weird hypothetical where
this is what he wanted it shifted from
here's what he's gonna do to here's what
he wants to do and then it gets into
some we have to stop him from doing the
thing he wanted to do but never did
so you're essentially an arsonist who's
never lit a match but you want to burn
down the synagogue but you never did but
I guess because I'm going to stop you
it's just a weird hypothetical world and
I don't know if you can ever win that
hypothetical argument you know you don't
think the [ __ ] is going to end at some
point you think it's just going to get
worse and worse
well I mean I can't imagine it being
worse than it already happened no it's
been [ __ ] brutal uh I mean the news
outlets have an endless
ability to churn you know what I mean so
they're gonna they're they're gonna do
what they're gonna do you know the
question is is sort of
people you know when do people hit a
saturation level like somebody said to
me
it's talking to Dr Drew on my podcast
and he said something about monkey pox
and I'm like I'm not whatever the cdc's
talking about I'm not I'm I'm no longer
listening I've just they they were so
full of [ __ ] with kova they got so many
things wrong I had so many people
telling me what to do and what not to do
and so much misreporting and so much
everything that I was just like
whatever Goodwill I had with the you
know with this group or that you know I
I've lived in this country my whole life
the CDC was like yeah whatever they tell
you to do you do it you know because
they're the they're the experts and they
don't have an agenda other than your
health the nation's health or whatever
it is
and I honestly that's how people felt
about CNN
a few years ago so good look it's
whatever CNN said that's that's what
happened like that's the news now
everyone's like oh sure oh so Trump took
a [ __ ] on the grave of the Unknown
Soldier who told you this happened oh no
one saw it oh one person saw it oh they
work for CNN like it's like now
everything is just dubious world and
it's really it's just a bad way to
relationship to have with news
or the CDC because they may be right I
mean there could be a pandemic coming
down the pike and the CDC could say Adam
here's what we need you to do and I'm
like yeah I'm gonna have another beer
[ __ ] and then I die you see what I'm
saying yes but that is a terrifying
place for America to be in because if
you no longer have faith in the
institutions does not really say you've
got no you don't really have faith in
America itself
I think you shift it to you know you get
back to sort of God guts and guns like
I'm no longer listening to what the FBI
experts have to say about Hunter Biden's
laptop you know what I mean they're 51
Security Experts signed off to say it
was it was fake Russian propaganda it's
like all right so these guys are experts
or fouchy or CDC or you know infectious
these like experts like or or Twitter or
Facebook like you're pulling off doctors
who disagree with you you're putting on
doctors who do who do agree with you I
think people are just going to have a
different relationship with experts so
to speak or even the FBI or or the
institutions and yeah it's definitely
going to erode
some of your
relationship with the government if you
hear the FBI or the CIA or the CDC or Dr
fauci or the Vice President says and you
go
sure it did yeah yeah and then you end
up going
well let's go over to sub stack and see
what these guys have to say about monkey
pox because I don't believe what the
president is saying about monkey pox you
know what I mean or or
or Don Lemon on CNN okay all right let
me go on so it's going to force people
to then go into these alternative places
and find information which which then
the mainstream will label as dangerous
misinformation except for it's like
dangerous misinformation who was right
about most of covet as as the dust
settles yeah
moving forward how do you think we heal
America Adam how do you think that we
bring we don't heal it because we're
foreign
um I think
you know ultimately
people have to understand that politics
used to be a very small boring
part of our culture that nobody really
wanted to talk about it at dinner party
nobody knew other people's politics it
was just sort of like I don't know that
guy votes I never asked why would I care
you know it's like a very
small group I have friends in Hollywood
you know who I I disagree with
politically but we're still great
friends and we just don't talk about
politics and we never did it's not like
we put a moratorium on talking about
politics we never talked about politics
this wasn't
we talk about comedy we talk about cars
you know talking about sports you know
we talk about you know good football
real football
I don't know there was no there wasn't
much room in it in in our conversation
for politics because it was considered
sort of uh boring and stuff old guys
talked about we want to talk about fun
stuff and so I think we I think we need
to just start tacting back toward a
place where it wasn't such a in the
Zeitgeist like it wasn't such a big part
of everyone's
day in and day out like I I never spoke
to my family about politics I it just
wasn't a it wasn't a thing and I think
we're gonna have to realize that
you know CNN or fox or whatever they may
want you to talk about all this stuff
but ultimately
that's them and that's that's them
getting paid ginning up interest in
something that's probably
detrimental like like look you can turn
on the TV and see a thousand commercials
for fast food it doesn't mean it's good
for you it means they're getting paid
but hopefully you're consuming it but at
some point you just have to step back
and not consume so we've got to make
politics boring again yes which we'll
try to do we do it on our show all the
time uh but Adam you've written the new
book
oh that's right it's right there yeah
there's a lot of copies of it here what
do you talk about
uh what's it about yeah well normally I
write a comedy book I just sit down and
think what do I think is funny and what
have I been ruminating on or thinking
about and then I sort of
tend to write it I guess that's how
everyone writes their comedy books but
in this book people are asking me
questions some celebrities and some fans
and they they're saying here's here's a
question and so now I'm now forced to go
I never considered that I was planning
on writing about this so
my past books I just drive around see
stuff that pissed me off and go oh my
God
damn Mexicans on Forest Lawn Drive well
there's a cop giving tickets out to
soccer moms give me that pen you know
this is people asking questions and then
I've I've been sort of forced into a
position where I go hmm I never I never
considered that and then it has forced
me to kind of stretch out grow a little
bit comedically because
I was just doing what I wanted to do in
in past books and the books were funny
but this is more like somebody asked me
a question
and they said it's 2022 men and women in
this country have basically gotten
gotten on an equal playing field and as
many men stay home and women go to work
and many men cook and the women bring
home the bacon and all that kind of
stuff but still when you see someone
riding a motorcycle the guys on front
and the woman's behind is 2022 like why
is that the standard
uh architecture of people on a
motorcycle because that goes back 50
years you know the patriarchy yeah the
patriarchy but why why is that still in
2022 when everyone is there's more women
lawyers and more women in college than
men and
and I remember just thinking that's
interesting yeah why is that because I
don't see it laid out any other way
and so I was like
what would what would explain that
and I thought
I think I have an answer
but it took me a minute I was like
because it is a very true statement but
it also wouldn't be true inside of a
college campus there's many female
professors now and female CEOs and stuff
like that and
I thought
a a progressive couple
that was more modern and more
Progressive and more of all these things
we talked about
would never own a motorcycle right it's
too dangerous right there was people
were double masking during covet and
wiping down their tennis shoes before
they walked into the house so the people
who are progressive
emotionally that way politically
whatever a motorcycle would be way too
dangerous for them to own they're all
driving Volvos with you know 15 airbags
in them and the people who would go out
and ride a motorcycle in this
dangerous days out there they are much
more traditional and they have a
different relationship with danger it's
a little more traditional like they
wouldn't be yelling at the kid to put a
helmet on when he was walking to the
bathroom you know and
and so it's a self-selecting group right
and that's why that's the only way you
see it right now yeah and I was
satisfied with that answer yeah I really
look forward to reading it because
you're a very funny guy and these
anecdotes will probably give you like we
haven't had a chance to read it yet but
I really look forward to it because the
anecdotes probably give you like great
launching pads to to go into stuff like
that yeah it was everything's a
launching pad for me but I you did I did
kind of do get a lot of questions and
went
he he was like it's kind of the
difference between going out and doing
stand up and kind of going here's what
I'm talking about and I got my set here
it is versus somebody in the room going
talk about and then they yell something
out you know and now it's like it's a
little different
dynamic and you're kind of going I
wasn't planning on talking about that
but now you're sort of challenged like
how do I make this interesting or funny
unique and what have you
given it wasn't something I was planning
on talking about and I found it be kind
of interesting that way Adam do you feel
constrained in your comedy more than you
did 10 20 years ago could you get away
with more stuff before than you could
now
um
you know I think it's all about sort of
how you position yourself and you know
if you
I say horrible things all day but no one
ever asked me to apologize because I've
sort of positioned myself as someone who
doesn't apologize so if you kind of
position yourself in a certain way then
you can avoid a lot of this stuff now I
don't know that it's going to help your
career that much per se but
for me I've always just kind of felt
like well I'm a comedian so I have some
license to say whatever I want to say
whenever I want to say it now we've kind
of changed the rules of that recently
but I never changed my mind on that rule
which is I I get to say what I want to
say because I'm a comedian I'm not
setting policy I'm telling jokes you
know and it's funny though I mean to be
honest you know you say to people
comedians always go it was a joke it was
a joke yeah it was a joke but I felt
that way I mean if I make a fat joke
about a skinny guy it's not really going
to work you know what I mean you got to
be that way so I joke about a million
things I do mean most of the things I
joke about but they're jokes so I get to
say what I want and my feeling is like
you know I I'm a carpenter I can go back
to swinging a hammer if I if I have to I
have a trade I could fall back on and I
would never want to compromise uh what I
want to say I just I feel like that's a
Faustian deal with the devil like it's
just why
why would you ever want to alter or even
trim what you what you have to say and
then I get their certain language and a
certain sign of the times and you know
that kind of stuff but
uh for me no and then also
you'll just find a new crowd who
appreciates a a your your your
authenticity I guess although I hate
that I call myself authentic yeah I
gotta take a rape shower but I I I just
mean I never looked at as having a
choice it's just like here's what I have
to say now I'm gonna say it this is not
open for negotiation and it's not it's
not because I'm Bolder hero or take a
stance or anything it's just like I talk
I have to say what I what I think
it's a sign of your success that that
you you can do that as well because when
you've got a big audience that I think
that probably makes it easier which is
great that's great for you Adam thank
you so much for your time I really
appreciate it we're going to ask you a
couple of questions for our supporters
only from our supporters but before we
do the last question for the main
interview is always the same which is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about as a society that you think we
really should be
well we're not talking about dads and
the importance of dads I think you know
we sit around and we kind of Chase
problems like what's going on with all
this street crime what's going on with
failing school systems you know what's
going on with all the substance abuse or
you know homelessness or suicide you
know prison overcrowding you know we
were kind of like
who are all these people in prisons you
know and then we do this thing where we
go
we need to either build more prisons or
just let the people out who are in
prison and my thing is is why don't we
find out why they're in prison like
maybe that's maybe that's something you
know what I mean like we have two
choices and my feeling is like maybe
there's a third choice which is like
where are their dads and what roles do
they play in their life and what the
hell happened
and dads are super important we somehow
decided that they were part of the
problem there's like toxic masculinity
or some nonsense they're not they're
vitally important we got in some weird
world where like she's a single mom and
she's doing her best and we applaud it
and no one goes where's it at where's
Dad we decided
that they didn't really have a role or
as an important role as they did in the
past everything we see is just an
offshoot of broken families absent dads
and bad parenting and were fools just to
chase it around like this guy he's 16 he
shot one guy then he went into the
system then he got let out then he
punched this woman in the push her onto
the tracks at the subway then he got
arrested again then he was out on the
street that afternoon it's like all
right we can follow that one kid around
it was costing us millions of dollars
because it gets into the system and so
on and so forth or we can try to go back
a little further and figure out where
the dad is how come the dad didn't raise
him correctly how come he didn't
discipline him out all the things you
get from that we could do that
politicians never do that
because that's like a third rail that
starts breaking down along racial lines
and and it turns into a nightmare so
they talk about
the problem which is essentially
the damage that the termites do but they
never talk about eradicating the
termites or how they got in the house or
whatever it is so there's like it'd be
like if an exterminator just chased
around ants and hit them with a slipper
individually it was like where's the
colony where are they coming from what
are they attracted to well they're like
moisture good you have a leaky pipe fix
the pipes that are attracted to the
moisture you know we're not we talk
about like root causes all the time we
never get to the root of everyone goes
why is there so much violence what's
going on this 15 year old boys punching
people on the subway it's like yeah
we're asked these guys where their dads
are go go to prison and find out
everyone's relationship with their dad
okay that's the problem that would fix
all the other problems around
we'll never we never talk about it
that's why we love Larry Eldon that's
why we've had him on the show he's very
good on that but I'm really glad that
white supremacist black guy
Adam thank you so much for your time
really great to chat with you uh I look
forward to reading the book I'm sure
everybody else watching listening does
as well uh thank you Adam and thank you
guys for watching listening we'll see
you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or also all of
them go out at 7 pm UK time and for
those of you who like your trigonometry
on the go it's also available as a
podcast we'll see on locals with a
couple of your questions for Adam in a
second take care and see you soon guys
Adam what have you changed your mind
about in the last five to ten years